well you dare enter this [__]
house on a Thursday you better come
prepared [__] I want to see
nothing but [__] and elbows on a
[__] Thursday pilot to Bombardier
pilot to Bombardier I see nothing but
clouds ahead pilot to Bombardier pilot
to Bombardier I see clouds I see danger
matte flavor coming through like a bad
[__] Thursday August 3rd get
slinging dick and giving out chopsticks
like a [__] you understand me
Uncle Joe is healing Joey where the [__]
you've been all week
you know what I've been busy [__]
I've been busy trying to take it up to
the next [__] level we learned
by [__] doing there nobody's [__]
at home write notes and making life
wonderful and all that [__] we're
going out there making it happen I
suggest you do the same [__] let's
smoke what the [__] haven't seen it's a
celebration it's a celebration fellas
drinks are on me no drinks are on the
house I'm saying now go home and get
your [__] shine box uncle Joey
this weekend we got me your podcast is
ready for you got to churches it's up
it's ready I don't want to hear [__]
nothing ok number two Saturday night the
Empire the [__] ice house 7:30 work
and I would uncle Joey 10 notes I bring
them all on stage and we talk [__] four
and I don't to have and you can do
whatever the [__] you want but number
three this is a personal favorite the
uncle Joey
tape the guestbook for me on TBS tonight
it's my brother Greg Garcia show he's a
bad [__] raising hope my name is
Sophie like any of those shows do me the
[__] favor
I don't ask you [__] for much
just DVR from here right I need this one
for my boy beside that will come see
come son it's time to smoke some
[__] reefer there's no [__]
stars at that dismal because I got a big
day on the [__] schedule okay I got a
meeting at jujitsu I got another meeting
and a lot of [__] Long Beach to the
Laugh Factory sir if you're in the
neighborhood 9:06 I'll be singing and
body I'll be [__] seat you know I'm
saying let's smoke another one here
because listen who knows what could
happen you get hit by a car today on the
way home god forbid so listen you gotta
smoke them why you got that's my [__]
model
oh [__]
perennial [__] sweet tooth and
I got a hybrid sativa over here behind
berry TSP this [__] will make
deemed our a stop stand and never stop
it I'm saying but uh hey that's it you
did it you made it through the toughest
part of the [__] week you're here
you're standing up straight and you left
the house this morning thinking somebody
it's gonna suck my dick today does
that's the mental attitude on a [__]
baby
everybody wants to know Joey motivate
listen the motivation is when you leave
in number one somebody's got to give me
a [__] I'm get I'm getting my
lunchbox back today and number two the
motivation is today somebody some one of
these [__] Moo peasant [__] there's
gonna sniff my nutsack today because
that's how I roll are they gonna sniff
it literally no I'm just saying your
[__] mind you're gonna do tremendous
they're gonna love you you can't [__]
lose if you go out today hey you go you
got a nice little tube over get away my
money don't worry about nothing I'm
still coming at you [__] you
know why cuz this Thursday you gotta be
prepared
always gotta be [__] prepared always
because you never know all these
[__] in there fo not me my
heads on a swivel like an offensive
lineman you don't say
and that's it that's net it's time to
spark a [__]
some of this appeal would get my team
down XD an ox I'm singing thunderstruck
you know that but that's it it's been a
great week
I hope you guys are happy that you guys
are here joining me I'm happy that you
guys are still out there taking a swing
and think Mia's remember always remember
without you I got who gots like a
[__] dick I got nothing
so I need you guys in tip-top Magoo the
stronger you get the stronger I [__]
get and as a [__] Church family we're
on a stoppable dog well unstoppable 20
years somebody's gonna be a little
[__] black spots with all the church
families of [__] congregating you
understand me trust my aunt on you this
I love smoking marijuana early in the
morning I love it out here in the Sun I
mean it's a beautiful day to be alive
that's just a [__] remind them it's
just a reminder how what lucky we are to
get up and be able to swing
[__] death all over again you
know saying every [__] day you know
it's so funny how people put dumb little
things there's a guy up here that just
keeps putting it something in Spanish I
can't believe you're that much of a
loser we're cool
you're that much of a loser that you
just sit there doing your thing and keep
retyping it how much of a loser are you
I mean I feel bad for you he'll even get
mad at people like you I pray for you
because not only are you jealous and you
you have every dirty emotion in you to
want to sit there on a periscope and say
things to people I see it constantly who
raised you do you even have any balls do
you even like yourself what the [__] do
you see when you're in the mirror what
do you see a [__] weak weak man if
you keep saying we'll go all the time
why don't you show up to one of my
[__] comedy shows and say it to my
face
and be a man about instead of a little
wet behind the screen your parents
[__] failed you your parents failed
you because they give you human decency
you just sit there on the stand and go
over and over and everybody even when
they're just having fun what type of
individual are you [__] putas a
mother to Iran a puta a Papa to EULA Mae
they don't bring that on corner because
your DNA you change the week how does it
feel to have weak [__] genes and to
know that you just sit on somebody's
periscope or somebody's timeline and the
somebody's Facebook
say little things like you're cute like
you're really [__] doing something
for the world you're a nothing you're a
zero and it's sad because [__] I know
what it feels like to be a zero but I
never had those [__] emotions that
would have to hide from a window and
throw rocks at somebody be a man that's
all life expects of you [__] Puerta
cuz that's what you are a little not
wait God ooh not wait that dough pillow
ooh not wait God or you'll ever be
that's all you family other behavior
when you have children they're gonna
turn out like you how sad is that
because if Amelia [__] kids you
transfer this garbage to your [__]
kids jesus [__] christ what is wrong
with society unbelievable people the
balls and we're not even producing men
no more what but do some like these have
[__] sapiens
no wonder they want to become [__]
shreddies
anyway we'll get the [__] about these
[__] don't forget I told you
you know I love you I got you the new
podcast is up and you're gonna have a
beautiful [__] thing this is why you
have to keep your eyes open at all times
and you add a stroke for people that are
walking around and they're just
miserable inside cuz they can't put two
and two the [__] together they've had
all the opportunities and they can't so
now they sit at home and they have
flipped hate on the world what a sad
state of [__] mind to be in man but
you know what [__] it you and I and the
rest of the church family we move a
little bit forward every day and that's
the most important [__] thing Joey
did Joey you're gonna Sparkle what yeah
I know I know
well here we are
it's Thursday we [__] made it
tomorrow is your lucky day and that's it
man there's the beauty about life you're
always working toward something
that's it and that's that
I'll see you [__] Saturday
night and if not I'll see you Sunday
night at 6:00 for another fun-filled
[__] podcast from the church I love
you [__] with all my heart if
it wasn't for you I'd have dick go out
there conquer your [__] dreams and
tell them all to suck your dick Boak oh
yeah they didn't care my my till I
Gbenga sorry that's the beautiful
[__] thing that's the beautiful
[__] thing about this life have a
great day you uncle Joey lotion